what did you want before Miami
I just wanted to escape my life
[Music]
do you like bartending it's not really
what I do what is it that you really
but then
you came along and gave me these
unexpected
magical moment
that made me remember who I really was
[Music]
let's go
why are you in London I'm gonna put on a
show at this famous theater
disconnected we can wake them up with a
wave of passion they've never felt
before
hell yeah without further Ado I give you
the Visionary artist magic mine
the real question is why do you love her
no one's believed in me like your mom
has
so what's the show about it's the same
or will she marry For Love or Money so
what does she pick
Ed the real question is why does she
feel like she has to choose it sounds to
me she just needs to let go
[Music]
and some good
maybe that as well
stand s
you're not shutting me down not this
time you're so good at this I'm not
gonna just let us give up on it I want
every woman that walks into this theater
to feel that a woman can have whatever
she wants whatever she wants there's
[Music]
this you were a cop right did you arrest
her what's your name Kim
let you out for the warning right
[Music]
I used to ask myself a lot of questions
Scott you're at ex-con
how are you an Avenger that doesn't make
sense
but everywhere I go people tell me the
same thing thank you Spiderman
people still need help Dad that's why we
made this
like a satellite for deep space but
Quanah wait wait a minute you're sending
a signal down to the quantum Realm
turn it off
now
[Music]
where
are we
listen to my own mind it's the secret
Universe beneath ours
what are you so afraid of
there's something I never told you do
it isn't what you think
[Music]
[Music]
I can get you home
and give you more time
if you help me
so
What's it gonna be
I spent the last seven years of my life
living out my wildest dreams
Bianca
Rocky
my dad
was built on their shoulders
hey my man can I help you let me get the
autograph no I ain't sounding an
autograph but you get off my car you
don't remember me huh
[Music]
Damien
how long were you locked up 18 Years bro
she's got out last week
I know I've been away a long time but I
got myself in shape I still got gas in
the tank come by the gym
thank you
[Music]
curious what happened with you too oh
you can tell you he was like brothers
I was the best though but I never got a
chance to prove that that's cute
I know what you doing Donnie you don't
always do nothing
Damien's fighting the world he's trying
to hurt people I bounce for you you
think you mad trying to spending half
your life in the cell
why did somebody else live your life
I'm coming for everything you
threatening me
something is going on with you
Damien was like family
[Music]
now we passed talking then maybe you
just have to find out
[Music]
these are Family Ties I recognize mine I
know that they needed me somatic stress
watching manifest got my only fair I
ain't scared of death did you hear me
did you hear me yet
I need you to make all your fear
look what a guilt
let go of whatever was and walk into
what is I feel those chains are breaking
yeah
[Music]
foreign
guys
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Charter 373
Commander Mills my ship was hit by an
undocumented asteroid
[Music]
transporting 35 passengers
from a long-range exploratory mission
[Music]
send help
[Music]
with crash landed on an Uncharted
Celestial body
[Music]
foreign
I've located One Survivor
[Music]
a child
the atmosphere is breathable
there's something alien out there
you need to be quiet and move
you and I are gonna get home oh finally
ready
[Applause]
I'm an idiot
I don't deserve these Powers if I'm
being honest like what am I even
contributing
wow there's already a superhero with a
red suit with a lightning bolt on it
Aquaman is literally huge and he's so
manly and Batman is so cool and I'm just
me
[Music]
I feel like a fraud it doesn't matter
um anyway a wizard gave me superpowers
and then everybody got super powers
where's everyone going
to fight crime
okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and I'm the only one trying to
keep it together
you understand I'm a pediatrician
right
come on
the fate of Your World depends on it
[Music]
children's told the power of all the
gods
pity
[Music]
look I might not have as much experience
as you because I'm not super old like
you but I've seen all of the Fast and
the Furious movies Lady it's all about
family
family guys that was a signal
introducing the star of our show
[Music]
your world will not survive this
so how we fight powers like this
you think I know how to fix this dude
but I really don't
everyone can be worthy
now go fight for your family go fight
for the world
I just threw a truck and a dragon I love
my life
[Music]
saying goodbyes
sing hello
you think your wife can hear you no
no don't wipe on
Maybe I'm Wrong
you're going to die
maybe not goodbye to you my trusted
friend
a new day is Dawning
new ideas no rules
no management we've known each other
since we were I need you
who is this the Martinez
challenge him to single combat with a
loose it's a way out
I don't sit at the table your family
does please pray for me
[Music]
man has to look his best when it's time
to get married
or buried I'm going to need a gun
goodbye my friend
[Music]
if you win
the table will honor its word
you'll have your freedom
under the old laws only one can survive
failure to meet at sunrise
will result in execution
Last Words Winston just have fun out
there
[Music]
I want you to find your peace but the
good death
only comes after good life
you and I left a good life behind a long
time ago my friend
thank you
here's the thing we're a team of Thieves
then when you do this
you're bound to make enemies
sometimes those enemies come looking for
Revenge
okay
truth be told
we helped the wrong person steal the
wrong thing
the greatest evil the world has ever
known
but we're gonna fix it so how do we pull
that off
uh figure it out over a drink probably
best you need
give us a fighting chance we're gonna
need strength you got this right I know
you don't
we also need courage
magic
and you
what is that again it's now there
go
be warned
there is evil here
I'm glad he's on our side
this one's dangerous
but whatever happens
we'll be ready
is it exactly that you bring to this I'm
a planner I make plans you've already
made the plant so the existing plan
fails I make a new plan so you make
plans that fail no he also plays the
loot not relevant
[Music]
[Music]
Mario Mario
oh my God okay
not sure if you know who I am but I'm
about to rule the world wow
yay but there's one problem there's a
human has a mustache just like you
think I know every human being with a
mustache wearing a magnetical outfit
with a hat with the letter of his first
name on it because I don't
know Hauser is coming
together we
are going to stop that monster how look
at us we're
horrible oh I got this no parabola
get it up get it up get it off
the huge Universe out there
with a lot of galaxies
they're all counting on us hello
pressure
we were gone for quite a while
but no matter what happens next
the Galaxy still needs its Guardians
hello we come in peace
but Drax seriously dude
all right
[Music]
don't forget
where we came from
[Music]
we have been running
our whole lives
I'm done running
[Applause]
Skies
[Applause]
we'll all fly away together
one last time
into the forever
[Music]
[Applause]
and we'll kill anyone who gets in our
way no not kill anyone kill a few people
kill no people kill one guy one stupid
guy who no one loves now you're just
making it sad
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
wish I could be
heart of that world
[Music]
[Music]
I can hear you being quiet mom
I am
hope I didn't ice your game man
no one my age says those words in that
order
it's just
see my little man not being my little
boy all the time
for years I've been taking care of this
little boy
making sure he is loved
that he feels like he belongs wherever
he wants to be
he wants to go on to the world and do
great big things
not bad kid
and what I worry about most
I love you miles
it was they won't look out for you like
us
miles
want to get out of here
wherever you go from here you have to
promise to take care of that little boy
for me
make sure he never forgets where he came
from
[Music]
he never doubts that he is loved
and he never lets anyone
tell him that he doesn't belong there
you gotta promise miles
I promise
[Music]
we are supposed to be the good guys we
are
[Music]
[Music]
over the stand down I'm not the one to
fear Prime
there is a Darkness coming
it was all a dream
whoever I'm not driving
away
of all the threats
from both your past
and future
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
and if you don't know that you know
[Music]
thank you
I miss the desert
I miss the sea
and I miss waking up every morning
wondering what wonderful Adventure the
new day will bring to us
those days have come and gone Perhaps
Perhaps not
I don't believe in magic
many times in my life
I've seen things
things I can't explain
and I've come to believe it's not so
much what you believe
so hard to believe
[Music]
who is this man I'm her Godfather
get back
[Music]
your days of fighting for the so-called
greater good
are over
this is our chance
show the truth
the concepts of right and wrong from
everyone for centuries to come
[Music]
you're fighting to save an ideal that
doesn't exist
never did
you need to pick a side
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
they won't fear it
until they understand it
[Music]
and they won't understand it
until they've used it
Theory will take you only so far
I don't know if we can be trusted
we're such a weapon
but we have no choice
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
since the first little girl ever existed
there have been dolls
but the dolls were always and forever
baby dolls
until
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]